Watching Hisoka is like watching Game of Thrones
jammed into a single character: Sex, violence,
questionable moral actions, intrigue and power.
He is undoubtedly one of the most iconic characters
in the history of anime, and if you have taken
away anything from the videos on this channel,
it's that popular characters are always successful,
because the author put a ton of blood, sweat
and tears into creating them. As we will see,
Hisoka is not giving you goosebumps because
he's so cool or strong or because his bungee
gum has the properties of gum and rubber.
Hisoka is so damn intriguing, because of all
the psychology Togashi has tied up in his
personality, because of the way he uses Hisoka
not only as a character, but as a storytelling
device, that makes hunter x hunter what it
is, and because Hisoka is purposefully designed
to not only manipulate the other characters,
but also to manipulate YOU dear viewer. Which
is why you love the story so much.
This might well be the most challenging character
analysis I have done so far. So buckle up.
This is the story of Hisoka Morow.
If I had to break it down into one sentence,
Hisoka is a manipulative, combat-addicted
and powerful player in the world of hunter
x hunter, that only acts based on what gives
him the most pleasure. The apex of hedonism.
- That were actually two sentences - Yeah,
yeah, okay, okay.
Part of Hisoka's charm comes from the fact
that we know barely anything about his past.
The only hint we ever get in the story, is
that Hisoka grew up in a state of poverty
coming to cherish even the humblest of luxuries
such as a piece of bungee gum. Now, since
this piece of information comes from Hisoka
himself, it's even unclear whether we can
trust the most manipulative person in anime
history, with being honest about his own past.
As we will explore in a moment however, it
is very plausible that he indeed had a quite
tragic past. In this context I also want to
briefly mention the one shot about Hisoka's
past made by Sui Ishida, the author of Tokyo
Goul. While not canon, it was acknowledged
by Togashi, and might be worked around in
the future. In case you are not familiar with
the piece, we get a short story about a heavily
injured Hisoka being taken in by a circus
troupe. How did he get injured? Where did
he come from? Where was he going? We have
no idea. All we know, according to Hisoka,
is that his mother apparently had some proficiency
in illusionist arts having taught him how
to use playing cards in various ways. Working
with the troupe, it becomes clear that Hisoka
was an absolute prodigy, being extremely confident
in his own capabilities and learning new skills,
including nen at an incredible speed. He gets
involved with the murderous doings of the
troups leader, who is murdering people for
pleasure. Perfectly summing up Hisoka's character,
he is the one to put an end to his killing,
all while showing off his own cruel and pleasure
driven side. And it's quite unclear whether
he does so out of a senes of morale or due
to his desire to fight and get stronger. He
even forms a sort of relationship with one
of the groups members, while at the same time
enjoying his own growth and dominance over
others. In the end, regardless of Hisoka's
intentions or efforts he found himself with
little option but to kill, and walk away.
It would seem that he is destined to find
and kill strong opponents. Not only does his
own twisted desire compel him to seek out
such, but even if he attempts a peaceful life...the
bloodshed seeks him.
And I think this shows really well, that the
truth behind Hisoka's hedonism is actually
some sort of trauma he must have lived through
in his past, that turned him into the sort
of cold psychopath he is. And while yes, Hisoka
is a really cool character, I hope it doesn't
come as too big a surprise that the man has
a pretty severe personality disorder. I talk
about this in a bit more detail in my analysis
of Sukuna, a similar type of character, if
you want to learn more about the psychology
behind this. The baseline is this: Hedonism,
in other words, fulfilling your every desire,
is not the same thing as happiness. And by
focusing solely on the present moment without
any regard for future consequences one oneself
and others, Hisoka completely stays clear
of his thinking back to his past. Through
combat, not only can he gain control about
who gets to hurt him, but he also can now
dominate people in return and get a sense
of importance and purpose, by delivering a
show for the audience.
That is Hisoka's true desire and drive as
a character. Satisfying his own desires, which
mostly is finding and fighting powerful people.
After all, he is a true tactical genius and
phenomenal martial artist himself. However,
I think the best way to understand how Hisoka
ticks, is by looking at his nen abilities.
Did you know for instance that Bungee gum
has the properties of both gum and rubber?
Just like killua, Hisoka also belongs to the
transmuter category, who's users are said
to be deceptive, fickle and driven by desire.
And I think there is probably no other character
that fits this description better than our
psychopathic clown. First of all deception.
Hisoka is arguably the best liar in the series.
Not just in the art of making false, but believable
statements; but in crafting meticulous, intricate
webs of deception that completely obscure
the truth. Hisoka literally means secretive
in Japanese, so you know it's one of his most
defining traits. He is a maser of manipulating
people, both in and outside of combat, often
putting multiple layers of lies on top of
each other. Hisoka uses this to divert attention,
create openings, hide his own weaknesses and
sometimes simply make his opponent suffer.
A great example for this is of course his
battle with Kastro. He willingly sacrifices
his arms to create an opening, divert attention,
and pretend having supernatural powers, at
the same time hiding the fact that he actually
DID injure himself, all while throwing his
opponent into utter madness, forcing him to
loose his cool and humiliating him in front
of the audience. Another example of this is
his prediction that Kastro would "die dancing".
Quite understandably, Kastro didn't believe
the words of a notorious liar and didn't give
it much thought. Meanwhile, people that have
come to know this aspect of Hisoka, such as
Gon and Killua may find themselves easily
trusting Hisoka's words at face value only
to find it was all a facade in the end. In
true Transmuter fashion only Hisoka himself
can ever know for certain what is truth and
what is lie.
Hisoka is also extremely fickle. Often, what
used to be a year-long obsession of his, can
become irrelevant to him in moments, like
with our example of Kastro, or his infiltration
of the Phantom Troupe.
And of course, the most defining trait of
Hisoka, his Hedonism that is driven and motivated
only by what makes him feel good. No matter
if it's becoming a member of the worlds most
dangerous criminal organization to fight their
leader or pushing two young boys to become
strong hunters in order to fight them in the
future, Hisoka doesn't let himself be deterred
from getting what he wants. Injury, failure
and even death only seem to make it all the
more fun for him. This hedonisms is expressed
by Hisoka in many ways, but I want to look
at two aspects in particular here: Sex and
violence.
Let's start with the latter. Hisoka is literally
addicted to fighting. As in he can't live
without it. And in this context I think it's
worth talking about his relationship with
the protagonist as well. Despite the differences
between Gon and Hisoka, the two find themselves
inextricably drawn to each other. On the surface,
both appear to be opposites, right down to
Hisoka’s appearance as a scary clown — the
mortal enemy of pre-pubescents everywhere
— but as the show continues their differences
blur into similarity.Both Gon and Hisoka
share the classic shounen trope of the warrior.
These are characters that are abnormally proficient
in battle, learn fast, tolerate pain and derive
a seemingly unhealthy, almost addictive level
of pleasure from it. Other such examples include
Kenpachi from Bleach, Sukuna from Jujutsu
Kaisen and of course Goku and Vegeta from
the Dragonball franchise. For these types
of characters there seems to be little choice.
Everything in their life seems to lead them
toward combat even if they try to avoid it.
In other words, this desire to better ones
powers and defining one's entire existence
through battle are not at all unique toHunter
x Hunter. However, while most shonen tend
to avoid the problems associated with this
stance, Togashi, as he so often likes to do,
calls out this issue, by making it a central
part of both Gon's and Hisoka's character.
The reason they enjoy fighting is that it
gives them a sense of importance, having people
notice and fear them, and gaining a sense
of control. They have the power to have an
impact on the world. As a great example of
this, and how strong Hisoka's influence on
Gon is, let's return to the fight in the Heaven's
arena, where Hisoka without any need to do
so, sacrifices an arm to prove his superiority,
satisfy his desire to dominate his foe and
gain the upper hand. Pun ABSOLUTELY intended.
Later, in the Greed Island arc, Gon mirrors
Hisoka’s sacrifice against the Genthru,
throwing away a carefully thought out plan
to dominate his foe.
But as if Hisoka was not already a masterpiece
of a manga character, subverting a number
of classic tropes and rules, Togashi decided
to do something even more unusual with his
character. Because based on his immense self-confidence
and as a way to express his hedonism, Hisoka's
character carries a very interesting sexual
element as well. And yes, I know it's probably
a bad idea discussing this, but hey, if you
like Hisoka that's part of his character.
That guy literally flaunts it in everyone's
face. It's like with real people, you only
get them as a package. - - Deal with it.
In general, in an industry that focuses heavily,
and often a bit too heavily on female sexuality,
Hisoka is a rare case of a male being over
sexualized. This is especially interesting,
as Hunter x Hunter is still considered a Shounen
story, a genre aimed at young boys with strong
heroes fighting against evil. SO not exactly
a scenario that requires a sexy, somewhat
queer man to be involved, but here we are.
This part of Hisoka's character is quite open
for interpretation, and it's meant to be that
way by Togashi. The main point of this, however
has actually surprisingly little to do with
sexuality in itself. Hisoka dressing and behaving
the way he does, are a visual representation
of him not giving a fuck about the rules and
embracing who he is. And since he is a hedonistic
magician, well, that's what you get. The other
thing is that for Hisoka, the line between
sexuality and violence is quite fluent and
often vanishes completely. Sigmund Freud would
be proud of Togashi. The much debated scene
where he gets aroused by walking behind killua
and gon, can of course again be interpreted
in many ways, but what gets overlooked, is
the fact that Hisoka in this scene gets aroused
by thinking about fighting Killua and Gon
once they have grown up. And while this aspect
of Hisoka might make some people uncomfortable,
it is exactly that fact that makes him such
a fascinating character. Hisoka doesn't care
what you think. And so this refreshing role-reversal
serves as a central element underlining who
Hisoka is as a person.
Many of these central traits, that we just
talked about, can also be found in the symbolism
of his character, that, you might find this
either very surprising or not at all, had
some inspiration from the Jojo series. For
instance, A central theme for Hisoka throughout
the story is the number 4, like the 44 name
tag, or his number 4 within the phantom troupe.
The 4 is an unlucky number in Japan. Maybe
you know that 4 is yon in Japanese. But there
is a second word for 4, which is shi, which
also means death. And death truly is all around
Hisoka. Another theme is that of the clown,
the fool or the joker, a very common trope
in storytelling. However, Hisoka is not the
the warmhearted fool, but the intelligent
trickster. This character is known for his
intelligence, is close to unpredictable and
due to their non-conformity incredibly irritating
to anyone who follows the general rules of
society. Next to Hisoka, another famous example
of this is of course the joker from batman,
who based on these same traits has reached
a similar level of popularity. As a clown,
Hisoka is of course also a performer. You
only see him fighting in a serious manner,
when he is facing a very strong opponent,
such as chrollo. Otherwise, the focus is always
on delivering a show for the audience, himself
and even his opponent. Always with another
twist and another ace up his sleeve, guiding
the audiences from act to act. From setup
to rising action, apparent defeat and a resolution.
If you want to go really meta here, you could
say that Togashi has created a storyteller
in his own story.
But even more than that, Hisoka is much more
than a interesting character, that enhances
the story. He is a carefully crafted narrative
tool, that shapes the story and characters
around him. Thus, Hisoka is, perhaps, one
of the most sutbtle but at the same time impactful
examples of Togashi's writing brilliance.
By making Hisoka purely hedonistic in nature
with no particular goal outside of being entertained
Hisoka can easily adapt to any purpose the
story requires of him. He is a true wildcard,
that in the true sense of a magician, can
take on any number roles, be it an ally or
antagonist. He is the one that enables Gon
passing the hunter exam and triggering his
desire to become stronger, ultimately forcing
him and killua to master nen. He is the one
that tips of Kurapika about the gathering
of the phantom troupe. And on greed island,
that already has a powerful antagonist, he
happily takes the side of the protagonists
to advance their respective interests. At
the same time, right from the start, Hisoka
is also the one shown to kill without warning
or hesitation, always oozing bloodlust and
as mentioned before, being fickle to the degree
that you can never be sure when he will stop
helping. During the chimera ant arc, where
the focus is on a new over-powerful antagonist
and gon and killua now have to show their
development and fend for themselves, it is
in no way unnatural for Hisoka, who wouldn't
fit the arc's theme, to be away somewhere,
chasing after Chrollo, only to reappear in
the next arc as an antagonist to Killua and
a force of nature during the Succession war
arc.
And next to his ability to seamlessly adapt
to any circumstances in the story, he also
is a wonderful tool to demonstrate the progression
of the story and to power-scale the other
characters. Due to his obsession with fighting,
we get a very good impression of how powerful
Hisoka is, giving us a great insight into
many of the characters he encounters. Hisoka
was always meant to be extremely strong, but
not Uber-powerful, like Netero or Meruem.
As a wild card he can be a powerful ally or
villain, but is never meant to be the main
antagonist.
The reason he's so good at showing us the
progression of the story and of the characters
around him, is not because of his ever-changing
wardrobe - though, let's be honest, it's always
Nice when anime characters bother to buy more
than one set of clothes. Not only fashion
wise, but also functionality wise. Jesus.
I mean this is fashionable. Uhm where was
I going with this again? Oh yeah, it's not
because of fashion, but because of his flat
character arc, that Hisoka makes a great mark
for character growth of Gon, Killua and co.
Character arcs are always about a character
believing something about the world, that
is false. In a positive arc, like killua,
it's about discovering this lie and rectifying
it and becoming a better person. In a negative
arc, like Gons, it's quite similar, with the
difference that at the moment of revelation,
in Gon's case his meeting with Pitou, the
central moral insight fails to happen, and
the character falls deeper into his lie, becoming
a worse person for it. A flat character arc
therefor, belongs to a character, that already
knows the truth. In the case of hunter x hunter,
this truth by the way, is the fact that people
usually aren't good or bad, they are grey
and morally highly complex people, driven
by desires, thoughts and the people around
them. Gon fails to realize this and keeps
believing that everyone is either good or
bad. Killua understands this after removing
illumine needle and thus finally becomes able
to love himself, despite his faults. Hisoka
already knows this. He knows who he is and
what he wants. Hisoka has learned to accept
the good and bad in himself and not be held
back by doubt or shame. Bow obviously, only
because a character understands the truth,
it doesn't mean he always does the right thing.
What makes flat characters interesting is
how they act based on their insight. It often
makes such characters a lot more versatile
and complex, as they can use this truth to
do both good and bad to the world. Thus, Hisoka
isn't just this one dimensional character
as some people like to believe. Which is why
I love the shower scene, which might be the
single most important moment of his character.
What the narrator is basically saying here
is "sit back, turn your brain off, and enjoy
the shitshow that is Hisoka's life." And since
Hisoka doesn't have to go through the same
process of learning the truth anymore as the
other characters, we can see their development
in comparison to the constant that is Hisokas
character.
And that brings me to the main point of this
video. Based on all that we have talked about,
all the fantastic writing and character design,
the thing that truly makes Hisoka a masterpiece
of storytelling, is the fact that You, dear
viewer are being manipulated by Hisoka as
well. As am I. This becomes clear in all the
controversy around him. Is he good or bad?
A role model or the worst type of person?
Relatable or repulsive? All these conflicting
emotions are the true genius behind Togashi's
writing. We get so many mixed informations
about this man, sometimes good, soemtimes
bad. Sometimes acting like a human, sometimes
like a monster. Sometimes telling the truth
and sometimes lying. Never showing any doubt
about himself or his beliefs. Is Hisoka actually
good at heart, but has a hard shell? Or is
he actually just cruel and selfish to the
core, manipulating us, just like the other
characters, into thinking he has a good side?
Or something in between? We will probably
never be able to tell. We love him for his
cool manner and his fantastic fighting skills,
but despise him for his cruelty and lies.
And so, all we can really do is get sweaty
hands whenever he shows up, not knowing if
we're gonna get the carrot or the stick. Togashi
created this character to thrust the central
moral argument of hunter x hunter into our
face. Human morality is complex. There is
no clear black and white. SO we might as well